[music]
[applause]
now, unfortunately, we see that
the ideology of Nazism, already in its
modern guise in its modern
manifestation, again creates direct threats to the
security of our country, we are again
and again forced to repulse the aggression of
the collective West is incredibly
Incredible, but the fact is that we are again threatened
German leopard tanks
on board which are crosses
and are again going to fight with Russia on the
soil of Ukraine with the hands of the subsequent Hitler
with the hands of Bandera, we know that despite
the efforts of the official corrupt
propaganda of essentially unfriendly Western Elites,
we have many friends, and all over the
world, including on  the American
Continent in North America in Europe,
but those who draw European
countries, including Germany, into the New
War with Russia and all the more
irresponsibly declare this as a
fait accompli,
those who expect
to win
a victory over Russia on the battlefield apparently do not
understand that  a modern war with Russia
will be completely different for them.
We don’t send our tanks to their borders,
but we have something to answer and the use of
armored vehicles will not end
[music] cheers
cheers cheers
Ukraine for me is absolutely all the
same, understand this and that’s it people We
must  to understand that we live on earth, we
must protect it, we must enjoy
life, be friends with children, everyone and do
good deeds. This is my conviction, so
for me it is all indivisible and it
seems to me that I am very sorry. I am no longer
the mothers of the wives of children who cry more
alive than those  Who is doing this for what?
maybe for the third time to
deprive Europe of
statehood so that they
understand that if they cannot
enjoy the
freedom and equality of peoples in the world,
then they must be deprived of it
[music]